humans will eventually have the
technology to change sex as easily
safely cheaply and reversibly as we
change clothes
that day is not today and could be 200
years from now but how do we ethically
bridge that gap given that it
necessarily involves experimentation on
kids and many failed cases will fall
into the uncanny valley
ain't never going to happen it's my
feeling yeah i think
i
knew that
i knew that i did and was almost certain
that you would reject the assumption of
the question which is in the first
sentence the first sentence being again
humans will eventually have the
technology to change sex as easily
safely cheaply and reversibly as we
change clothes
it's i mean it's
frankly it's easy to say no way
when you add reversibly
as we change clothes there
you know
is it
barely within the realm of possibility
that we could have the capacity to
change all of the systems
um
once and only once thus making a human
an actual a single individual human an
actual one-time functional hermaphrodite
i don't think so but that's at least
something that we could talk about with
regard to the complexity of the systems
and all of this but the idea of kind of
going back and forth and actually being
functional as the other sex
it's just it's it's just too much
there's just no way yeah i i don't think
um
[Music]
i think it is barely plausible
that in a small number of cells you
could make an alteration that would
cause
an individual to go down the alternative
pathway it would be irreversible and it
would be pointless to do it in a small
number of cells you might as well do it
at the gamete i mean at the zygote
so you have a single cell and this i
mean this is the point actually right
like um we talk about sexual development
right it's not a toggle it's not like
there are two states and so the states
are binary and we think of zeros and
ones and like oh just make the zero one
just make the one is here like no it
takes years it takes years and no we're
not a metamorphic species but we do go
through puberty which is a kind of like
metamorphosis light and so you can't
just say um you know turn those
i don't even know what the analogies are
i know we know them they're the homologs
but like
turn the female reproductive structures
into male ones like it it can't work
that way and so you know
the only thing that i see her as a
remote possibility and why would you
ever
is
could we develop the technology to turn
for instance an xx embryo
into a functional
male
adult you know into someone that
developed through puberty as male into a
functional male adult
maybe
but that would
like why right like why would you do
that
[Laughter]
why
yes why would you do that and
um
anything that starts later or imagines
that you could do it multiple times
uh or you know or or forgets that it's
not just
it's not just reproductive it's not just
the primary sex characteristics right
it's it there is masculinization or
feminization of the brain
of
the endocrine system and there are with
regard to endocrinology
there are effects of hormones especially
the steroid hormones especially the sex
hormones like the androgens testosterone
and stomadione like the estrogens
and progesterone
which have not just activation effects
which is to say ah turn it on now get um
you know a rush of energy i don't know
but also organizational effects which is
to say
when
you have
those hormones in development they
organize your system so that those
systems then follow different pathways
you become canalized
and those developmental systems can't
just suddenly become other things they
would have to go through a whole other
developmental process in order to be so
so it strikes me in
thinking about this in this context
that
this has a lot to do with actually the
last question about immaturity and the
point is
everything that we perceive
is inherently the reason that we bother
perceiving it the reason that we bother
thinking about it is about the future
you may be dwelling on the past but
you're dwelling on the past because the
past has some implication that is worth
spending your effort on the past cannot
be changed and this is like an obsession
with changing the past
right
the idea of i was born in the wrong body
is instead of saying well okay here are
the cards i was dealt you know um maybe
you're a
uh
a woman with
a very masculine orientation to the
world
okay what are you gonna make of that the
answer is you can make a lot of that
right
you are such a woman right
or
you could lament the fact that something
and something else don't fit together in
the way that somebody told you they were
supposed to and then you know you can
rail against the
you know the cursed biology and try to
go back and un-biology it and
you know it's like okay a
it's not liable to work all that well
um and b it miss you know it's a
misorientation the point is look if you
walk out into the street and you get hit
by a bus and you lose your arm
yep you're going to end up grieving your
arm but at some point and it's going to
be the best moment of your life going
forward you're going to move on right
right you're going to say well i am a
person with one arm and
um
[Music]
let's live my best life with one arm
because it's about the future
irrespective of whether you got you know
you may have gotten hit by a drunk
driver and you lost your arm are you is
it okay to be mad yes but the point is
if what you are is mad from then on then
you won't do any of the things that you
might do even with just the one arm
[Music]
you